[Music]
you were always so impeccably dressed
well thank you Conan well you are you
have a very I was at a Christmas party
with you I remember and you showed up
the Christmas party and you were I said
at the time you were dressed like John
Wilkes Booth you had the hanging chain
with the fob it looked like all you
needed was the derringer in a theater
you know is this amazing well look Sic
Semper Tyrannis first of all yeah
effectively yes I'm a bit of a clothing
wise I'm a bit of a horse about it yeah
you could say that I'm a clothes horse
yeah enjoy clothing I mean look at this
you've got the the the tie is matching I
haven't seen anyone do that in years
yeah fantastic the watchband matches the
shoes which are green that's true
incredible yeah it's lined up perfectly
you're clearly insane yeah now I see
that I think that somebody's running
from something
I found you it's your own fault
you put these if you posted these like
the beginning of this interview that
starts with you know you Instagram
photos of yourself as a kid and take a
look at these now my god is that a
bowtie I like that it looks like you're
being attacked by a large mob that is
grown seventies man's bone tie that I
was thrilled to be wearing for first
grayza you were doing this as a kid you
know I love your gradually growing into
the boat that was a three-piece suit
reversible vests I was very thrilled
about it so this is it's no accident
okay I'm just gonna say to you growing
up if I went to school and I was wearing
that bow tie I'd have been beaten
senseless did kids pick on you kids you
know kids are kids
and you know you you grow and you put
things behind you and it doesn't you
know okay like what am I gonna do well
hum that forever
okay maybe that was a bad subject for me
to bring up I apologize
you're crying blood let's move off your
clothes that's clearly a painful subject
from your past they need to traveling
any traveling uh well Conan I travel all
across this great land of ours yes do we
end up I'm doing uh I think I'm gonna be
in three cities in the next four days
which is that's mental illness don't do
that what I'm a married man I should be
home with my wife yes you should but I
am taking a trip with my wife I'm doing
a week of shows in Charleston South
Carolina
with a very funny comedy group called
super-ego and we're going to for the
week we're gonna be staying at a beach
house on Sullivan's Island which is
where my wife grew up which is wonderful
place in in South Carolina that I love
because it has a certain flavor to it
this I will tell you a story this is a
business story about Sullivan's Island
in the in the 80s there was a doctor on
Sullivan's Island who for reasons that
were acceptable in the 80s had in his
possession a human foot in a freezer in
his garage this is before there were
laws that's against the law now a human
foot a fig now I think it's frowned upon
right to have human feet in a freezer by
your home right but this is the 80s
yes he ankled blingo was at the top of
the charts and the president was on
cocaine yeah exactly
so this the his his his human body part
freezer in his garage they were
suffering a power failure and so rather
than let these treasures go to waste
this doctor as he later told authorities
decided he would take this opportunity
to study the ligaments of the human foot
so he put this foot in a crab trap and
lowered it into the sea well wouldn't
you know but that during foot got out of
that old crab trap
and it washed up on the beach on
Sullivan's Island and people lost their
minds because they thought a maniac was
loose and cutting people up and so there
was a manhunt that was put on and then
eventually this doctor had to step
forward and say yeah I might could have
put that foot in a crab trap
[Laughter]